[Music]
on today's show we talked to a woman
with a newborn at home and her and her
husband are not on the same page we also
talk to a woman who loves her husband
but she's beginning to lose respect for
him we talked to a young man who's got
three kids and he's losing his faith and
he wants to know what to do stay tuned
[Music]
what is up this is john with the dr john
dolone show hope you're doing well
wherever you happen to be whatever
happens to be going on in your world
glad you're with us the show we talk
about mental health relationships
everything if you want to be on this
show i'd love to have you go to
johndaloni.com
ask ask
you're into the new year and you already
are
out to eat with your family staring at
each other
just
looking
and you like no screens no no
get the john de loni conversation cards
get online and get them they're awesome
we finally got new shipments in because
they sold out with three runs man one
two it was awesome now we're back so get
them
for your cup for your for your s for
your relationship for your dating
whatever nice words john good job i
should i should run a podcast for you
for your dating relationships for family
get-togethers friend get-togethers kids
got cards for everybody it's good hey
ben kelly
i hit send on the manuscript man for
this book it's nice
you know what i did last night i went to
bed it's my first non-20-hour day in a
long time and it is awesome so good and
that means kelly's life's better too
because i'm a little bit more pleasant
her to be around
i'm always pleasant around ben
it's just killing i appreciate it it
just brings out in my heart it's cool
man i'm excited i'm excited all right
let's get to the
actually hold on i want to do one thing
real quick
before we get to the telephones
um i'm going to pull something up on the
internets here that somebody sent these
somebody sent me on my dms
and i won't use her name
but
i
love this
all right here's what they write ready
for this
just listening to your information on
cry it out i think it was on ama it's
the first time i wasn't 100 on board
with you at first my heart started
racing and i began to talk to my car
radio that's where i listened to your
show and getting defensive
then i stopped practice my skills and
asked where this is coming from it's
coming from a mental health professional
who sleep trained her children and wants
to be validated that she's a good mom
comes from a woman who had postpartum
depression with her first child and
taken care of
um of them was extremely hard comes from
someone who reads so much on sleep
training co-sleeping and crying out it
hit a nerve to say the least i agree
with you the fact that cried out with
any child is not the way like baby cries
and you never go in i agree the sleep
training with a one month old is
terrible and traumatic but we disagree
at some point however
even i as i write this i realize i'm
seeking validation and reassurance that
i'm a good mom
i am
so i'm sorry for impulsively blowing up
your dms on friday morning looks like i
need a stories journal just like you so
i don't blow up podcasters dms just to
come to the conclusion i did
and had lots of errors i'm sorry i'm
done now listen
you know who you are who wrote this
number one good for you for
disagreeing i love that i love that i
don't know a lot but i know i'm not
right on everything probably not right
on a lot of ben's nodding his head he's
like yeah you're not writing a lot of
things
but
man thank you for disagreeing thank you
for writing thank you for being
like treating me with dignity when you
wrote back to say hey
i like you but you're you're super wrong
you missed the boat on this one and then
thinking through why am i so mad
oh man i'm mad because or why am i hurt
why am i defensive because this is
challenging a core belief of mine and we
get to the bottom and our core beliefs
might still be different
fantastic
so good
so good i'm so grateful that you wrote
me this and i'm grateful that you were
thinking through it and i know it's
gonna rattle around your head and you're
going to ask your friends you're all
going to talk about it good we're
inspiring conversation that's good
that's good that's good so thanks for
writing in i'm grateful for you hey if
you disagree with me on stuff write me
and let me know be nice no actually i
don't care for being about it it makes
me laugh but but let me know and if you
think yeah i hadn't thought that through
but that's that actually sounds right
let me know that too i'd love to hear it
love to hear it all right let's go now
go to the phone let's go to sarah in
jacksonville florida what's up sarah how
are we doing
hi i'm good you're good
yeah i'm good i'm good too fantastic so
what's up how can i help
um so
i had a baby about four months ago
congratulations i'm just thank you and
i'm just wondering how to i guess get my
husband and i on the same i guess
parenting page
um
i want him to be a little bit more
hands-on than he is and to enjoy it i
guess
until he doesn't enjoy it
there's a lot here huh
a bit yeah yeah it sounds like him um
how was your marriage before you got
pregnant
um pretty good i mean we
we waited a long time um
purposefully
um how long have you been married
that ten years today actually
okay
so yeah
this thing that was gonna be the
greatest thing that ever happened to you
and it's gonna change your life and
you're gonna find love that you didn't
even know existed has basically ruined
your husband's life
uh i think yeah pretty much
and then he feels guilty for even
thinking that and you get mad for him
even thinking that but your life's kind
of ruined too and but you love him and
you love the baby and now we just got a
big mess
um kind of i guess
um
sometimes it's great and then um
sometimes like basically when the baby's
happy everyone's happy
and fortunately he's a pretty happy baby
but when he's a baby and
he
is overwhelmed or
hungary or he's just a baby
yeah he's a baby
so he's gonna cry he's gonna
be needy he's gonna want to be held
because he's a
baby exactly
or like he spits up
a lot because
baby
exactly he's a baby
and he
like i get i was telling my husband i'm
like i get spit up on multiple times a
day i basically live and spit up
that's amazing and it's disgusting you
kind of ruined the podcast today thanks
for that just kidding
well i mean again it's normal he
you burp him he spits up and sometimes
burp cloth is not in the right spot and
when you're by yourself you can't put it
in the right spot yes but um
but
so when you say your husband like
what is he doing
um so i guess for example he hasn't done
this in a while but that's because i'm
i'm a confrontational person and i
confronted him about it
but
he
was
he got a new
set of pajamas he got spit up on the
night that he
got them
and he got mad like
he
like as though the baby did this on
purpose
yeah like it was purposeful
and he
he gets upset because
the baby will cry with him or not me or
like he'll go to sleep for me but not
him that's because you're a mom and he's
been plugged into you for a year now
yeah so i explained
or is he is his is his picture of what
this was going to be just way off
i think it's a little bit of both okay
um he doesn't think he's as sensitive as
he is
i know he's very sensitive no man does
right no man does
well it doesn't help that he's actually
he's a marine okay um and
so
he and then the way he grew up it was
kind of like you're not allowed to have
feelings and
um
i don't want that for our son right and
i told him that i told him that last
night actually
um
when i was giving him resources on how
we can deal with um like tantrums come
toddler stage because it feels like it's
fast approaching
um even though he's only four months old
but um
i kind of
i was like he's allowed to cry he's
guys have feelings and i don't want him
to be one of those men
that
only ever feels rage because they can't
identify their feelings right
good for you
what did he say to that
um
he tried to kind he got defensive
he kind of tried to be like well
men don't have feelings kind of thing
and like boys don't cry and i was like
you i pointed out to him i was like
you don't know how to
have feelings other than anger right and
and we joke all the time that he only
has one feeling yeah like when people
say like oh you've hurt my feelings or
like
hit me right in the fields we joke he
has won
so i'm pretty good at hitting that
feeling
we can look around at the
suicide rates and the heart attack rates
and the stroke rates and the cancer
rates of men and we can golf clap for
all of us
we won we got we got rid of the feelings
and our bodies paid a price they're
paying a price we're dying you know what
i
mean
um but you know that that's yeah if he
calls me we can have that conversation i
won't i won't get all fired up this
morning on that
um so
there's two things at play here number
one
you can
really focus on the best parts of
somebody and
just kind of roll off the other stuff
until you bring kids in because in a
kid's a walking it's a mirror for both
of you and
now you're talking about what are we
gonna how are we gonna connect and
that's that part's not going so yeah
there is part of your husband's story
that i wanna give to him you've put up
with stuff for a decade you've known
this about him for 10 years
and it's just been part of it and y'all
have even turned it into jokes into
laughs and it's probably reared its head
a few times
and you said not anymore and he's been
like cool and what
and now
it all becomes real
real
right yeah so some of that
as part of the conversation you're gonna
have to own i've put up with this for 10
years and this ends
yeah okay
um the second thing is
is i want to honor the fact that you've
got a
strong
feeling free man who's doing the best he
can with the limited set of tools and
this sounds ridiculous the word that i
always use over and over especially with
military veterans especially with first
responders who have who
as part of their training takes their
feelings and puts them in a box because
their feelings will get them other
people killed right yeah and so those
things that work on the battlefield
destroy homes and they destroy
neighborhoods and they destroy
like uh
cultures because
you've got to use you know you don't
get a screw out with a hammer you got to
use different tools for different things
so
yeah he's going to have to practice
what this looks like and you as his
partner for a decade now
are going to be the person who's going
to help walk him through this so
here's a couple things we can
walk through sounds like he's missing
his old life is there some of that or
does it sound like yeah i think he faces
something he can't control
okay we both kind of are it doesn't help
that he was gone for basically the
entire pregnancy yep um he was in
training and um
it's just the way the timing went it's
so funny because we actually planned to
have kids when he would be home
and
we had a miscarriage in march like right
as the lockdown started in 2020
and then
by the time we were ready to try again
he he got selected for something
important
and i i had already known like in my gut
it was gonna happen this way right
kind of like
you have plans but god's plans are
better right so you've had a year to
adjust to this and i'm not giving him a
pass you've had a year um the baby is a
part of you and when he was your husband
was gone this baby in some ways
yeah i mean y'all are super tight right
yeah yeah um and so i don't want to give
him he's got to grow your husband's got
to grow up babies yeah yeah babies crap
everywhere they barf everywhere they
scream and they're babies
and i do have to give them a lot of
credit because i i was induced
um
due to like preeclampsia and had to have
an emergency c-section after pushing for
three hours yeah and um so i was really
out of it
for the first basically six weeks yes if
not more and so he was he did a lot he's
changed more diapers than me he's
done more i guess carrying
of a lot of things than i have and we
moved three weeks after i gave birth on
top of it gosh so he's a he's a pretty
great human being right oh yeah he's
he's great he's a great husband i think
he has the potential to be a great
father i just have to i've just been
having to push him a little bit more
than i thought i would okay so here's
what i want you to do okay
first thing is i want you all to get
somebody are y'all do you live on base
or you live in your own place yeah okay
i want you to get somebody to come watch
your baby one morning and y'all go out
and you've heard me say this a thousand
times i'll say it a thousand more times
i want you to take a
like a spiral notebook or a
notebook of some sort but get online and
buy some obnoxious fancy one whatever it
is
and i want you guys to write down
what parts of your old life you miss i
want you to have a grieving breakfast
together
what was
we should be able to do this and you go
first and you're practicing this you go
first we used to be able to stay up all
night and drink all night and dance all
night and we used to be able to just hop
up and take off and do this and what
what can we not do now
what is different about our relationship
and what is about this old life that we
loved what are some things about the old
life we didn't love but here's where we
are
and then you're going to spend some time
saying what could this look like
and here's where that's important you've
got to get your husband who for how long
has he has he been in for it for 10
years
uh he's been in for almost 15 or 16
years okay so
he has been wired
yeah to see
challenges as a mission and accomplish
that mission
yeah
and you can't accomplish fatherhood
it's a relationship
and this is new
yeah and i kind of i guess when it all
this kind of initially came to a head i
kind of i told him that i was like
because he doesn't really have
his relationship with his family is uh
how are you doing great of course good
he's got he's got no model for this yeah
he's never seen this done he's never
seen it done that's that's why you gotta
practice
i kind of told him i was like i don't
want that for you guys yes and so here's
where that becomes important i want you
to when you're talking about the things
that you're excited about this new
chapter because your old life is over
and the quicker you all realize that the
quicker you can be about building
something new your new life is i mean
your old life is over for better or
worse and now here we are
and so you can say what do we what do we
want this to look like
okay so he has a model of
a dad who treated him x y or z or a mom
a treatment xyz and now this is the
result is their current relationship
yeah and so that means we're gonna have
to do things different
so um
reverse engineering all the way back to
your dad never ever
hugged you
your dad never held you your dad didn't
take you to the store get gas with him
your dad didn't take make the the trip
to the gas station 10 times longer just
so you could practice getting get like
you didn't know these things
that's what we're going to do
what could we do to get this picture
that's going to be different then
and you see those dads on base when they
see their sons and man nothing gets me
choked up like
a hardcore
marine
all decked out whose dad shows up and
both of them end up like slobbering
crying because they love each other and
you see them on base you know what i'm
talking about yeah yeah i do and then
you see the ones that show up and
there's this weird stoic they shake
hands like like like when they're
dropping their kid off or they're you
know helping them move they shake hands
like they've just completed a
transaction
yeah like goodbye son goodbye dad and
they shake hands like thanks for the car
thanks for the
hug your kit right so you're gonna have
to practice these things and you're
gonna have to
come up with some sort of language with
him
which is
i'm not gonna call it out during a fight
that's a terrible thing
but i want to have some language where i
can say will you hold the baby and
you'll say on it
because we're gonna practice
relationship like what's going on what's
wrong nothing i just want you to hold
him just because
and over time he will go
now i
sit on the couch i don't like sitting on
the couch by myself anymore now i want
to be under a pile of kids and that's
weird for me but i've been practicing
for a long time okay yeah and i want you
to know he can get there
not a mission it's a relationships whole
thing is new new new
the thing about going out to breakfast
is it is
not um
i'm trying to think of a military
analogy
in the middle of battle is not the time
it's not the time to talk strategy
to
redo your game plan you're in it you do
that when you're not at war and a nice
breakfast a good going out to lunch
together that's not war
and you going first keeps it from being
war like here's the things that yes
right
how does that sound
um it sounds good i just
um
i guess
i'm trying to think of like a when
because we're
we're going home next not this coming
week but the following week we're going
back to where we're from it's going to
be it's literally like a cross-country
trip so hey
that could be a incredible time to talk
yeah you're going to be together if you
do the work now and come up with a
hundred questions or 50 questions
or
and they're not
how are you going to be the guy who hugs
all the time how are you no it's
paint me a picture of what you would
like if you're dropping your kid off at
college what would you want that to look
like
like do you want to hug him when you
like paint that picture and just reverse
engineer it
imagine dropping your kid off to be
maybe he wants his kids to go to service
too maybe um
like what do you want that to look like
you want to be one of those dads at hogs
you want to be one of those dads that
handshakes or one of those that does the
weird side pat like what cut what do you
want to be right and let's reverse the
gender how do we get there now what's
the most frustrating thing about having
a kid what's the
what's the your favorite part about
having a new kid and here's the thing
when you ask those questions he's not
gonna admit it but those are feelings
what's my favorite thing about having a
kid huh
i like him when he just looks up at me
and smiles what's the worst thing when
he likes you more than me well yeah
your husband's got to grow up on that
one dude that just happens that's life
right and then that will slowly start to
shift and then you'll get mad that he
likes your dad husband more and you'll
say things like i carried you nine
months and all that kind of stuff will
come up too right
but the thing is is to pull the air out
of this balloon because it's gonna burst
at some point let the air out
you're practicing you're working he's
doing something he's never seen done
before and that's cool and that's scary
and it's terrifying
and all those things together
thank you for your service as a military
well i thank him for his service for man
15 years of putting it putting himself
in harm's way on my behalf and my
family's back i'm grateful for you y'all
can do this spend this it's been this
season cross-country driving
and talking for the first time
maybe feeling something we'll be right
back in the dr john the luna show
[Music]
studies show that a lot of us dread
going to sleep at night maybe it's
because we're stressed because we didn't
finish everything during the day or
because our thoughts just won't stop
spinning or maybe our spouse snores so
loud or maybe our bed's 100 years old
and it's just not comfortable whatever
it is anticipating a bad night of sleep
sets us up to be miserable we get better
deeper rest when we look forward to
sleep and that's why it's so important
to create a sleep environment you love
jumping into for me the mattress is
critical but also pillows are key i hate
bad pillows but i got my dream cloud
mattress and they sent me these dream
cloud pillows and dude
they are incredible i can't wait to go
to sleep and you know what that helps me
sleep better now pillows aren't the only
accessory dream cloud makes to optimize
sleep they have luxury sheets they got
mattress protectors you name it and
today when you order a dream cloud
mattress you get
399 bucks of these incredible sleep
accessories and on top of that dr john
delaney's show listeners get an
additional 250 bucks off that's 649 in
savings not to mention some really good
sleep if you need better sleep check it
out at
dreamcloudsleep.com promo code
deloney
all right we are back let's go to
elizabeth in greenville south carolina
what's up elizabeth
hi thanks so much for taking my call
thank you what's going on
well my husband started his very first
ministry job about 18 months ago and i'm
afraid he's going to get fired
hey and i don't know how to help
i know i know it's not funny
but i'm laughing anyway how long have
you all been married
we've been married about seven years and
what did he do before he started working
for jesus
i'm assuming that is that kind of
ministry
yeah definitely jesus ministry nothing
else
you said well actually i was like oh man
i missed the boat on this one
well he was actually a former navy guy
so the last call was actually kind of
really pertinent to our situation here
former navy
and then was a professional graduate
student for a couple of years those are
the marriage
i was one of those
we got through it we got through it and
now he's here in this job and um it's
been really tough
so why do you think he's gonna get fired
he um
he's a youth pastor and so
he's constantly fielding
um complaints
from parents about his
lack of organization and lack of admin
skills um
and then
recently he
heard from the head pastor that he
doesn't feel like he respects him
and
um
the pastor's wife was actually
volunteering with the youth group for a
while and she just
messaged the entire committee that my
husband reports to and says i'm i'm not
helping anymore um
and if you guys want to hear about my
experience working under
this youth pastor please let me know
um so it just seems like
what was your husband's response to that
they actually this is all like in real
time
so
they have a phone call about it later
today and she's a counselor so i
i trust her to be very you know
forthcoming and honest and mature about
the situation oh elizabeth i know a lot
of really immature counselors oh man but
hopefully she's hopeful she's great um
have you have you talked to her called
her directly
because there's this messiness when
you're at a church
um that also has administrative hr stuff
because in like it would be way out of
bounds for
my boss here where i work to get mad at
me and then my wife to call him
um
it would also be weird for somebody who
doesn't work here to volunteer to help
to join the john doloni team
and then to write a report and be like
that was a disaster which it kind of is
that was a disaster and if you want
mike's i mean so the whole thing's a
mess
um
but i think i'd reach out and talk to
her that's just side side thing y'all
have any relationship at all
yeah we do we actually um
we have really great terms and i feel
like she she could definitely share
stuff with me and we kind of
she's a new um pastor's wife too like
they've only been married for um about a
year
so we've both kind of been thrust into
these positions of okay our husbands
have weird jobs
and
we you know have relationships with
people in the congregation
and they complain about our husbands and
but you know we're trying to have
connections in community um and it's
really hard to kind of differentiate uh
it's a disaster it's an absolute train
wreck of a mess yes oh yeah which is why
uh pastors and especially their spouses
end up some of the loneliest people on
the planet because they got nowhere to
go
you know what i mean they end up with
nowhere to go
uh yeah and it's it's brutal and the
hard part is like
what
what normally happens is the spouses of
the current ministers become really
close
and then one day you say hey i found
something at our house or my husband
expressed this and i'm worried about it
and now
you're going to your friend with a
concern
but now it's just become an hr issue
yeah right and so the whole thing's a
mess it's just messy messy messy i
personally don't like that the pastor's
wife did like recon on your husband i
don't like that i wish it had been a
little more upfront
um sounds anyway that's that's beside
the point so what does your husband say
about all this does he know he's got a
problem
yeah he's really been he's been working
on it
on his administrative stuff and the
thing is is that i'm i'm really good at
it
and i do marketing and public relations
so i'm
you know i'm very type a and very good
at getting the word out about
events and things like that i mean like
i could just like sleep before
with
you know with the communication style
um and so when i try to step in to help
him kind of and give him suggestions
it's it's usually well received but
um
i don't know how to
stop myself from scrolling over
him and doing his job for him but at the
same time when he's receiving complaints
about
you know
parents don't know about this event or
we don't have enough people signed up to
go to
you know a fun activity out of town it's
usually because he hasn't
really done due diligence on making
connections with the parents and making
sure they all know what's going on so
can we back out for a second
how much of this is you're scared your
husband's gonna lose his job and how
much of this is you're super frustrated
that
like
like he's he's not doing basic tenants
of the job and it happens to be the
parts that you're really good at too
yeah can i tell you where this is really
hitting home for me my wife is a
master teacher an incredible k-12
teacher she's just
like a she's just a stud
and
she came and visited my classroom once
when i was teaching high school
and her quote to me was i don't know
what that was but that's not teaching
and i was like what are you talking
about i'm incredible and she's like
that's actually incorrect you're not
credible
and so
it actually became a thing where she we
never talked about it because we did it
so differently and it drove her crazy
and it's that's what i'm hearing a
little bit in your voice your husband's
about to get fired that we can talk
about that but it also sounds like
you're losing respect for the guy that
you're married to because he can't do
basic things that you do really well is
that fair
wow um
losing respect i
i
yeah i guess so it just kind of seems
like gosh why why can't you just
get it together or you know why can't
you just why can't you just piece these
parts together and how can you not see
when you
put the word out about something the day
before an event of course people aren't
going to show up absolutely
why is he choosing why is he choosing
that successful why is he choosing that
i have a couple of different working
theories um oh this will be said to me
would you like my thesis statement um
my guess is a he doesn't like this job
it's not what he thought it was going to
be
or b
um he's overwhelmed or c he's lazy
what do you think i think it's
a mixture of b and c okay maybe a little
bit of a thrown in um
he might
what i've noticed is
the little details that really matter to
people especially to other people on
staff
he feels like he's above them
um oh he better recognize him he better
recognize him yeah
wow well and like meeting deadlines for
things that
you know he just he thinks our small
potatoes in the grand scheme of things
um
are
he neglects and so i'm constantly like
you have to like this matters to someone
it might not matter to you but it
matters to someone and the fact that
you're
kind of digging your heels in and not
doing this um
it it's not great and that you know
causes tension and the team is really
small and so when you it's like five or
six people falls on somebody oh yeah
yeah so you know you know you know
what's heartbreaking here
two things number one
people i work with may have had a
similar conversation with me in the last
couple years and two
um
not from the beneath thing i don't i
don't jive with that there's no job here
beneath any of us um
the big thing is i had this conversation
with my 10 year old or 11 year old
recently
my 11 year old
and this is like a this is a very
immature man
this is a maturity issue
you know what i mean it's a choice issue
and here at where i work where you know
dave ramsey's the ceo you'll see dave
picking up trash in a parking lot
he got a debt we all got a deadline the
other day on some book stuff and he was
the first one done
and he had more to do than i did
and he has infinitely less time
available than i do
you know what i mean like so
it's a maturity issue and i know that's
frustrating for you as your wife
has this always been this way does he
does he treat you like this did he treat
his navy career like this surely not
you really don't have an opportunity to
act that way in the navy
officer you've got
you've got people that you report to
you've got a very systematic
thing
you know working for you
so the deal is he can do it if he
chooses and if he chooses not to because
it's beneath him that's a character
issue and he shouldn't be a pastor
um you know what i mean because he's
teaching young people that things are
beneath him
that there will come i mean i don't want
that type of character around young
people
i want a youth my dad after he quit
being a cop for a long time became a
youth pastor and dude he was the first
one there six in the morning and he
would get home at 2 a.m that next night
because he was cleaning up the bus in
the parking lot
that's the guy i want around my kids you
know what i mean
and i know this is hard because it's
your husband
that's why i ask you is there a respect
issue here
yeah i mean when i think about
even the way that
he treats stuff around the house you
know like
i've fought really hard not to be the
type of
woman who argues about how the
dishwasher is loaded here and there but
i told him
after he had this conversation with the
pastor where he said i feel like you
don't respect me i was like you know i
i kind of
get that if you're
doing something you might not be doing
something directly to say i disrespected
you but you might not be doing something
that indicates
you know
exactly exactly not respectful so here's
here's a gift you can give him
and that is
by not kind of saying things a little
bit
maybe-ish
you deserve to be respected
and you deserve to have your voice heard
in your home
and he
might he might take off
who knows hopefully not
he
he might
start to get it
when you stand up and say
for 10 years or 15 years how long
however long we've been married seven
years
you've never emptied i mean you've never
done this dishwasher the right way and
i'm telling you this is somebody whose
wife did that for me and it ended up
being a gift
and when you say when i ask you to do
something like this around here and you
and you dismiss it
i feel disrespected i feel less than i
feel like you think you are more
valuable than me that's the story i tell
myself and he needs to hear that because
this may be the first time he's heard
some of these things
and at some point i hate to tell you
this he's gonna have to get fired or
have some sort of big awakening
before this type of character stuff
shifts because he's walking around the
world as though
it all revolves around
him is that fair you're so yeah you're
so right i've never seen it like that
before but you're right
he probably complains about the way they
made his steak or his burger or his
whatever or they can't believe they
cleaned my car like this but everything
is a
through a lens of
how does it impact me
not
as the heart of a minister should be and
the heart of a husband should be
how does this impact my wife and the
people that whose kids i'm taking care
of
right
most of the ministers i work with
have given so much of themselves to
everyone around them that they've got
nothing left for themselves this is the
inverse of that
here's what i think you do i think you
after the call today hopefully he's
still employed
my guess is um he will be but he'll have
some strict stuff
in this moment i think it's valuable if
you all get out of your home and you go
somewhere and like i told the last
caller
and you tell him
this stuff that's being told to you is
right i feel it too as your wife and i'm
willing to walk alongside you as you
begin to
as you change your lens you change your
glasses on how you're going to begin to
interact with the world
because we have to have a world of
service if you're a minister you can
have a world of service if you're a
husband you've got service if you're a
wife you'll serve serve serve
and this thing's going to be done inside
out
and in my life here's what that means
don't ever be late again never
cause it's it's a it somebody else has
to pick that stuff up somebody else has
to have a conversation with somebody if
i'm late kelly's got to tell the caller
sorry we're running behind here she's
got to clean up my mess james has to
i create ripple effects when i do that
or if i don't park in the right place or
if i don't get my money turned in or if
i don't fill in whatever it happens to
be
if i don't get my emails turned in
whatever
this is about dignity and respect and
you all need to sit down have that hard
conversation and for what it's worth he
feels it on you elizabeth he feels
you
looking at him looking down at him look
like almost disgust almost like what are
you doing what
it's good to get that stuff out
it's good to get that stuff out we'll be
right back on the doctor john delaney
show
one of the most common questions folks
ask me is what they should do in anxiety
or panic strikes like a lightning bolt
i've been helping folks 101 for years
but i wanted to create something that
everyone could use anywhere at any time
so i created a free guided meditation
it's not really a meditation but really
me just walking with you through your
anxiety alarms from start to finish i'll
guide you through a breathing exercise
and show you how to lean in listen and
head towards healing it is free and it's
for everyone you can download this
guided meditation today for free at
johndaloni.com
all right we are back let's go to sean
in salt lake city to the utes what's up
sean
hey how you doing dr john i'm good
brother what's up dude how can i help
good well hopefully this will be an easy
answer for you but um
those are never there's never easy
answers go for it well we'll try to give
you a softball um
so i grew up in the uh very devout
mormon family here in utah and uh
it really controlled everything i did um
any decisions i made that kind of stuff
it just like we went along with the
church and uh
recently you know i've some of my
beliefs have changed and that kind of
stuff and
i don't know if you call it a faith
crisis or what but
i'm just trying to get some guidance on
how to maneuver through that
quote-unquote faith crisis so i don't
spin out and get in a bad spot yeah
number one thanks for your bravery
brother and um
spinning out's part of the process
unfortunately for the people who
actually pay attention and are committed
to any sort of faith walk if you don't
have a crisis at some point i don't
think you're really digging in because
this stuff's hard
um
how uh
how old are you
i'm 35 35 okay so what brought about
this is you've been reading you've been
listening you just kind of been rolling
your eyes you got kids all of a sudden
like what what what's leading to this
yeah so i mean i've got three kids that
are eight six and three and um
you know just kind of teaching them
things that that i learned growing up
and then
and then yeah just been reading some
stuff and
um
the history of the church and things
like that that didn't fit right with me
and i felt like
that wasn't
taught to me correctly when i was a kid
so in a way i kind of felt betrayed
and
that's kind of where it just
started so you know i've been trying to
you know teach my kids values and morals
and that kind of stuff because and that
doesn't change i think that's
that's what you should do as a father
right um yeah yes yes values and morals
are good
it's fathering 101 yes
yeah
so that's that's where it really came
from as i just you know started
learning more and digging deeper into
things and it just
kind of shook me weird and yeah are you
married that's a challenge i am yeah
how is your wife
what's your thoughts on this
um she's right where i am you know she
didn't have the same upbringing that i
did um
her parents
didn't really raise her in the church
which is cool but um
but yeah she's she's very supportive and
she'll walk right alongside me i just
i want to make sure that i'm
strong and you know going to leave my
family correctly and not just
like i said earlier spin out and
okay not handle it right so do you have
what are you scared of
uh have you said like what are you
scared of doing
i mean
are you are you are you done with the
church
i feel like i am but yeah like i'm kind
of i'm scared to even say that because
you know in in this area it just
dominates so much of our social life and
our culture yep yep
and i'm afraid that you're gonna lose
everything i mean you're gonna lose your
community your friend community probably
your parents i mean you're gonna lose a
lot right
yeah yeah and that's what i'm scared of
and i don't want
that so you're not getting you're not
scared of getting struck by lightning or
like burning in hell or whatever i don't
know what the end result of your faith
is but you're you're more concerned
about like you love these people and you
still want to go to dinner you still
have christmas parties and stuff yeah
yeah like i mean i still want to be
around and be involved in everything and
all that i just don't
maybe i'm scared of what people think of
me and you know that kind of stuff and
have you
have you sat down with any of your close
friends and let them know where you're
at
yeah yeah i have how'd that go
it was good it was good they're really
supportive about it and um
you know some of them even agreed and
kind of going through the same thing
that i am yeah so i mean it's good we're
kind of built it's
it's a smaller community that's for sure
yeah a smaller community of people who
are asking questions or who are thinking
through things or who want to do life a
little bit differently
yeah okay
um
so i've been where you are thinking
through like uh man where i'm at where
i'm learning and where i'm growing is
different than how i grew up so let's
take let's take religion off the table
because that's that can feel jarring
let's put parenting on the table
which is also jarring but here we are
right um
i don't know anybody
that's not true maybe a couple maybe a
couple who want to reproduce exactly
verbatim
the parenting that they received when
they're considering how they're going to
parent their kids
almost everyone i know has some sort of
there was some really great stuff there
was some
some neutral stuff and there's some
stuff i'm absolutely gonna do
differently with my kids
now do we actually end up doing that we
all talk about you know i hear my dad's
voice coming out of my mouth and i'm
like what is that like one time i even
looked behind me because it sounded like
him
and
anyway so
we have that and so the the
mark of maturity the mark of growing up
the mark of wisdom is
can i hold in one hand
the things about my parents the way they
raised me that i didn't like that i'm
gonna do differently and
can i still hold the good parts and the
parts that respect them the parts that
love them deeply
and if you can do both
that's wisdom can you hold both sides
and and go forward
right that's wisdom
most cannot
most have to burn down the other things
so they can before they feel like they
can cross a bridge
and i think that's what's wrong with the
world right now
i can't possibly talk about climate
science without having to
also back everything on this side of the
political aisle or i can't possibly talk
about economics without having to and
and capitalism without having to you
know what i mean imagine showing up to
get your deer process pulling out of a
prius i thought the poor guy was gonna i
thought his head was gonna explode right
yeah that's the world we're in right now
and so what i want people to do is to
begin to to understand there's a both
hand to it
here's what that is you whether you want
to admit it or not and i think you did
just admit it so i'm not going to put
words in your mouth there you got some
good stuff growing up in the church
absolutely you got some good values you
got some a weekly connection you got a
tribe you got a crew you got a you got
some good stuff
and
over time you've the the the buzzword
now is deconstruction you're beginning
to walk your faith back and go
it was built on something i didn't
realize that was built on and most of us
think well if the foundation's wonky if
the if the story here is wonky then the
whole thing's one and that's where i'm
gonna say
the journey that you're on is both and
can i re-imagine re-read re-walk through
rethink re-whatever this foundation part
the story part the
did that thing really happen like that
because it sounds bonkers
and not throw the whole thing away
and what i'll tell you is
i spent a season
years as just a functioning atheist i
mean the whole thing was just ridiculous
and then over time and i and i actually
came around it backwards i started doing
crisis work and meeting with people who
were dead in the middle of the night and
they're loved and i found it in a much
more truthful visceral way than i had
originally
and so what i would tell you is my
season of disconnection was one of the
was incr was super important there's
years they tell you don't plant your
fields so that that soil can
like
become really rich so that when seeds do
get planted they grow deep
okay
and
let me tell you this if you're not
honest with your community
they're not your community you don't
have community because you're lying to
them
and so living
in authentically just so you can be
around people
is inauthentic right it's it
you become that guy
i feel like that's been been me living
inauthentically for
for the last couple years yeah
it's exhausting brother struggle yeah so
let me tell you some bananas about brain
science your brain knows you are not
connected
and your brain knows you're lonely even
when you're surrounded by people
yeah and so
don't put yourself in a situation where
you are with people that you are lying
to or hiding from or pretending with
because your brain's gonna start
sounding the alarms you're not safe here
you're not safe here you're not safe
here
it's much better to be authentic and i
love that you've already had some of
these conversations and it's often faith
crisis faith conversations or did we
really believe that when we were kids
versus this and why right most of the
time
you're shocked by how many people around
you
think that way
nobody just has said it yet and when one
person says it everyone's like oh thank
god yeah that's crazy you know what i
mean and then
and then there's people on a spectrum
who are great people they're great
people of character they get great
morals and they don't they don't believe
any of it anymore it's just now i'm out
and there's those that actually get more
entrenched more conservative over time
and they're still my friends too right
right
i think what you've got to do is make
peace with what you actually believe
have you spent a minute writing down
here's what i believe right now
you know i've i've actually started that
i've been listening to your shows for
quite a while and
i've been writing my wife letters
um awesome
and that's been that's cool did she
write you back just getting it under my
brain yeah
she i'm better at writing and she's
better at uh talking it through so cool
awesome yeah it's been it's been good
well that's that's phenomenal so let me
leave you with this okay
okay
i hope that my values
never change
i hope that my values where i treat
people with dignity respect i'm a person
of curiosity
i'm a person of character
i've got several core values
i'm a person who believes in god i have
core values
i hope those never change
i hope my beliefs change
radically throughout my life
because then if not why listen to a
podcast why listen why read books why
hang out with other people
why
because the reason we do that is to
learn new things i believed when i was a
kid that plants just grew and then i
learned about chlorophyll and borophil
i learned my beliefs about how plants
grow changed
i want that to be the same in my faith i
want that to be the same in parenting
and it's when we can go oh my gosh i did
xyz for all these years and then
i learned i was hurting people i got to
stop
right and we grieve it then we go on to
the next thing so i want you to hold
your beliefs loosely and begin to dig in
on yourself be curious with yourself not
judgmental
and here's the
go ahead
i was just gonna say i think it's it's
taking me a little while to accept
um that asking questions
is okay yeah now you're on to it
that's one of my core values is i will
always ask questions
and if i find myself in a institution or
an enterprise that says no questions are
able to be asked here
and by the way behind closed doors i
work for dave ramsey i've asked him
questions about debt and he's answered
them and i said yeah but what about this
and come on man like just just you and
me dude we're hanging out by ourselves
what about this and he's talked so
i'm in a culture where i can ask
questions
because that's one of my values
belief answers we may come out to
different answers but the beliefs and i
i do agree with dave on that stuff but
the beliefs man i want those to be all
over the place you do have permission
asked questions in any place that tells
you you don't have permission
um is a is a is a place that's hiding
something
it's okay to ask questions that's a
cornerstone of wisdom right that's a
cornerstone of searching
faith is not knowing everything and the
opposite was it and lamont the opposite
of faith is not doubt the office
opposite of faith is certainty
i'll say that again the opposite of
faith is not doubt the opposite of faith
is certainty
and so man
going through life certain is a scary
proposition
going through life holding it loosely
and saying wow what's next while
tethered to your values tethered deeply
to those values
really really important
find a mentor that you can talk to
someone who's five years 10 years 20
years down the road um they actually
have deconstruction coaches a friend of
mine justin mcroberts folks like that
who will walk alongside you and help you
think through some of these things
what's the good parts of my faith what's
the what's the parts that i need to let
sit down i need to move on where else
can i go what's what our values look
like when they're untethered a little
bit
people like justin mcgraw folks who are
actual coaches just like a therapist but
they walk alongside you they're
incredible
i recommend you grab somebody like that
and help you walk through this season
your kids are lucky to have you
continue to be a person at character
continue to be honest continue to ask
good questions and continue to show up
show up show up thank you so much sean
all right as we wrap up today's show
oh
man kelly picked the song of the day
she is just sitting
on the dock of the bay oh this redding
one of the greatest songs ever written
goes like this
sitting in the morning sun i'll be
sitting when the evening comes
watching the ships roll in
then i watch them roll away again
i left my home in georgia headed for the
frisco bay because i've got nothing to
live for looks like nothing's going to
come my way looks like nothing's going
to change everything seems to stay the
same i can't do what 10 people tell me
to do so i guess i'll remain the same
i'm sitting on the dock of the bay
watching the tide roll away i'm sitting
on the dock of the bay wasting time
looks a lot like kelly when she's
working on this show we'll see you soon
on the dr john delaney show